seit sonntag ist minecraft endlich als
early access version öffentlich
zugänglich mannschaftsrat verspricht
minecraft in die realität zu bringen und
ein einzigartiges erlebnis mit einem
freund im wohnzimmer im park oder auf
der straße das prinzip dabei ist recht
simpel man läuft im echten leben herum
mit gps bewegt sich auch seine
spielfigur auf der karte und man sah mit
items blöcke tiere oder kisten dann kann
man eine bauwelt auswählen diese mit
seinem smartphone auf eine beliebige
oberfläche projizieren lassen und los
bauen
das funktioniert tatsächlich auch
richtig gut und es macht echt spaß durch
sein handy in einer minecraft herum zu
fliegen und richtig nah an sachen heran
zu gehen oder seine breite von weiter
entfernung aus neben also einen anderen
sachen zu bewundern
schon vor zehn jahren haben die
minecraft spieler einen faszination
darin gefunden die grenzen des spiels
herauszufinden und zu versprechen wie
tief kann man gehen wo ist das ende der
map und wie hoch kann man bauen was ein
computer schon interessant ist ist in
der minecraft version von raelert in der
relativ oft noch viel spannender
stellt euch vor dem echten leben seid
ihr auf wenn man lernen wie sie aber
wenn ihr durch eure handys befindet ihr
euch inzwischen kilometer hoher
touristischer und magischer gebäude und
strukturen er baut von euch und euren
freunden also wie hoch kann man in
minecraft maximal bauen bis an die
zimmerdecke oder bis zu ich bin jetzt
bei der domplatte und mein ziel ist es
irgendwie ein turm zu bauen der so hoch
ist wie der dom platziert dass man hier
hin und dann ist schon krass wir können
jetzt natürlich alle möglichen sachen
hier kaputt machen wir sehen uns als
zwischen leute rumlaufen und das ist
halt echt schon ziemlich nass zu sehen
wie hier aber so meine freundin hat
sonst einfach keiner sieht jetzt können
wir hier schon erde nähen und jetzt
können wir uns auf
und ich könnte die ganze zeit nicht aber
wir können jetzt hier blätter hoch bauen
und jetzt können wir nur hoch bauen aber
irgendwann bin ich noch immer nicht groß
genug also das hat jetzt schon geil aber
wenn wir den trüben so groß machen
wollen wie den gesamten dom
dann müssen wir uns einfallen das ist
übrigens der kameramann ja hier beim
schwein ist es witzig das ist richtig
cool also keine schweinchen ok um die
grenzen von minecraft wird
herauszufinden gibt es natürlich mehrere
möglichkeiten zum beispiel könnte man
hier so an dem kran benutzen man könnte
auch den aufzug vom dom benutzen
allerdings würde man dafür
wahrscheinlich keine genehmigung
bekommen es gäbe auch noch die option
das handy an eine tour ohne zu schnallen
aber ich glaube ich habe noch eine
bessere idee okay da fahren ist es jetzt
ein okay der plan ist es jetzt einfach
das was wir schon gebaut haben da hin zu
setzen dann einfacher hoch zu gehen und
dann von oben quasi zu bauen
ich mache es einfach mal die straße
würde ich nicht hier versperren wir
wahrscheinlich die straße aber ist auch
egal jetzt muss ich ja so zurückgehen so
dass man das immer noch die ganze zeit
im blickfeld
das ist natürlich ein stück i jedoch
absolut dämlich aus so jetzt bin ich
hier oben ich kann jetzt einfach hier
von oben drauf weiter bauen wir tricksen
das game komplett aus wir können jetzt
an den abnormal hohen
überdimensionierten turm bauen so wie
wärs denn wenn wir da oben noch ein
hühnchen drauf setzen würden im sinne
der wissenschaft haben jetzt hier in
extrem hohen turm und der ist nämlich
schon ziemlich hoch aber der so nicht
ganz so wie der dom und deswegen müssen
wir noch ein paar bugs benutzen um den
noch größer zu kriegen weil
logischerweise wenn ich ihn jetzt
hinstellt ist es natürlich schwer jetzt
aus dem haus zu gehen und dennoch sei
darauf zu bauen bevor wir jetzt zu dem
abkommen mit dem man in minecraft zu
bauen kann wie man möchte muss ich
natürlich erst mal materialien sammeln
und laufe dafür quer durch köln
ich spiele jetzt gerade zu zweit in
dieser welt und versuchen jetzt einfach
mal den turm noch höher zu bauen damit
wir den daneben den dom stellen können
und machen
wir können einfach hier die ganzen
blöcke weg machen und dann damit unseren
turm richtig hochbau wie dumm sie das
grab von außen aus es ist also gut mal
hätten ist und wer ist der tote schon
gehört gemäss sind gibt es echte wollen
wir jetzt denn da block darunter sitzen
[Gelächter]
alle leute werden
ok also ich will jetzt versuchen den
turm wirklich erregen sie zu machen und
dafür muss ich noch mal den bakken
bisschen hause nutzen und ich will dann
hühnchen ganz oben drauf setzen oder das
hühnchen muss dann höher sein als der
kölner dom der übrigens 157 meter großes
der trick ist wenn man einmal drauf
gekommen ist eigentlich ziemlich einfach
man muss einfach nur mit seinem handy
eine gewisse fläche an fokussieren dann
die kamera zu denken damit das handy
nicht mehr verfolgen kann wie man sich
gerade bewegt dann einige schritte nach
vorne gehen die kamera dann wieder
auftreten damit das objekt wieder
platziert werden kann dann wieder einige
schritte zurückgehen und schon haben wir
unser bauwerk einige meter in den boden
reingeschoben und den schritt kann man
dann einfach immer wieder wiederholen
plötzlich mit kranken liga
ich hab mein block geschafft ich bin wie
seine grenzen also irgendwas versuch zu
treffen auf seinem handy da geht aber
einiges hier
die kamera ich glaube ich habe ich
dachte werden das ende erreicht aber
mein stack steine waren auch ultra viel
erde
ich glaube wirklich dass wir großartig
glaube hat deswegen die grenze oh mein
gott okay wir haben offiziell die grenze
erreicht es geht einfach wirklich gar
nicht mehr hörig würde mal gerne wissen
wie die blogger das jetzt waren wir
gehen jetzt zum domplatz ihren das ganze
damals schon einmal die kleinen der dom
im vergleich zu unserem turm aussieht
okay jetzt im moment der wahrheit wir
bauen das gebilde vor dem dom zeigt und
gucken jetzt wie großer größte dort
türmen dieser erde wirklich geworden ist
erst elf größer also dom
jetzt wissen wir dass das pauli mit wohl
auf normalen wege so schnell keine
erreichen wird die größte baufläche die
ich bisher gefunden habe war übrigens 16
mal 16 blöcke was ich möchte sagen ein
bisschen gering finde und ich hoffe dass
das ich hab nachgezählt und das bauen
mit ist aktuell ungefähr 240 blöcke was
meiner meinung nach wirklich mehr als
ausreichend ist wenn ihr jetzt noch mehr
von minecraft erzählen möchte dann geht
darüber zu meinem neuen zweikanalton auf
dem ich ein komplettes letzte playoff-
gelernt haben indem ich einfach spiele
und auszugeben
diesmal das geld aus der tasche ziehen
möchte und was man in game und in dem
video werde ich nicht nur ein
dreckhaufen bauen mannschaft ist dafür
bekannt dass man sich dabei seine
grenzenlose kreativität verlieren kann
und mein team und ich leben unsere
flexibilität gerade dadurch aus dass wir
an einem rpg minecraft server arbeiten
die kursk lassen so was wie magie und
krieger handel unfall eine starke
gemeinschaft zwischen den spielern ist
dabei der schwerpunkt weil man das
interessiert könnt ihr jetzt gern das
diskont beitreten und wenn ihr
interessiert mitzuhelfen dann gut meine
wie die beschreibung stehen alle infos
und wenn er mich auf dieser reise
begleiten
harmonie ist klar und dann sehen wir
zunächst mal wieder macht's gut
aber wenn ihr auf eurem handy gut
befindet ihr euch und zwischen kilometer
hohe futuristischer
[Musik]